all right in a few weeks a giant auto
plant employing twelve hundred and fifty
people will go idle in Lordstown Ohio
it's one of five in North America where
General Motors is stopping production
the plant is in Trumbull County where
thousands rely on GM directly and
indirectly for their livelihoods it's
also a county that voted for President
Obama and then for president Trump CBS
News contributor Stevens keep who's also
co-host of NPR's Morning Edition and up
first went to Lourdes town to find out
what residents are thinking now Steve
good morning good morning we talked with
people over three meals in Ohio we've
done this elsewhere because you learn
about people when you share a meal
[Music]
nieces country cafe opens around dawn
it's just down the street from the GM
plant that is the center of life in
Lordstown Ohio hi guys these retirees
meet each Friday morning Sam worked at a
plant that has endured so long they
doubt it's really shutting down 41 years
I've been there 41 years I've heard this
I don't believe they're gonna close
David Farkas is hoping GM will revive
the plant that supported his family but
two girls through college have a new car
two new cars every year got a beautiful
home I did everything a rich man does
because I was rich General Motors money
these retirees did well enough to
collect classic cars like the Chevy
Impala Dona Schrader keeps their garage
[Music]
this plant is so huge that since the
1960's it has produced 16 million
vehicles so huge that we had to drive
five miles to go on a loop around it
Lawrencetown home of the cruise you get
a sense of the pride in this community
from that side this car was a big part
of General Motors recovery after the
Great Recession a popular car for years
now GM is ending North American
production because smaller cars are less
popular and that's bad news for this
plant no matter how well the workers
have done their job it's also bad news
for every business that serves GM
workers like our place diner
its majority of everything in this
community manager Jackie Woodward
watched in recent years as GM laid off
her husband and her brother and then
everybody else what did you think when
you heard my heart was broken it's hard
to see people that you've known your
whole life you've grown up with them and
then all of a sudden they have to pick
up and they have to move their families
we invited Ohio senators to meet us for
lunch Democrat sherrod Brown how many
years and Republican Rob Portman are
from different parties but her friends
who share a talent for working a room
your dad was active duty yes sir and a
desire to keep the plant open Browne
recalls President Obama's auto bailout
you know Tammy taxpayers save this
company and then they get this huge tax
cut Portman argues GM's prospects should
be improving a few things have happened
just in the last year in the Trump
administration that would make it more
advantageous to invest here I gotta have
the GM chicken fenders both met GM chief
executive Mary Barra who said she was
open to ideas for now laid off workers
can transfer but it's not that simple I
mean you own a house in Youngstown and
there's a plant closing or significant
layoffs your chances of selling that
house aren't very high as you guys know
the president came to this area in 2017
and said industrial jobs are coming back
don't leave don't sell your houses it's
gonna be great
that hasn't turned out to be the case
well some businesses have been helped a
lot by his steel tariffs there's a lot
of great research and development going
on there now a lot of innovation
advanced manufacturing is big so there's
some positive things but this
when is a it's it's a punch in the gut
[Music]
the restaurant manager at lunch put us
in touch with some GM workers who've now
arranged to meet us for dinner at the
sunrise in in the old manufacturing city
of Warren Ohio so many workers came to
share their stories that we had to pull
up extra chairs for me and my wife
having a disabled daughter or our whole
support system for her is here
it's been a long fight with the schools
and with getting everything to where it
is it's it's taking us ten years and
thousands of dollars that if we have to
move it's gonna go back to square one so
if General Motors says there's a job for
you in Fort Wayne there's a job for you
in Flint Michigan I either go there and
quit General Motors and after 25 years
that's a hard pill to swallow moving is
hard when others need you to stay I take
care of my elderly parents it's hard I
take them to their appointments go to
her pharmacy get of their meds and I see
no use in you have to be away from his
son my kids would have to be away from
their dad
how many people here voted for Trump one
two three four about half of you
some still back in but Marsh is like
this Ohio County he voted for Obama then
for Trump and it's deciding where to
place his hope next my loyalty is done
to either party you know I'm gonna vote
for who I think is talking the right at
the right time for the people at this
table with almost 150 years of GM
experience the job was more than a job
what have you loved about working for GM
now our jobs are coming to that part of
Ohio a retail distribution center will
hire about a thousand but likely for
lower pay GM is offering workers
retraining and it's possible that auto
plant could revive Tesla expressed some
interest but for now the GM workers face
a choice between their work family and
their real families what a difficult
choice Steve Inskeep thank you very much
for that report just reminds you again
guys that there are people human beings
yes yes and backs and figures the
effects rippled out through a whole town
through families it snakes everywhere
and as one of the senators says it's a
real punch in the gut yeah well and Mary
Barra though is needing to transform a
great American company you know as we
transition to electric vehicles and so
she's changing that way that company is
they do have jobs in other places it
shows you how difficult when you have a
family it's easier when you're younger
but when you have a family an old early
parent the thing is so many of those
auto companies in towns like that have
been just massive institutions yeah that
have threaded through families for
generations showing it is really she's
trying to keep the company alive and
keep it profitable which is not doing it